hey what's up guys just hot off the
press we thought that we had a technical
issue and it turns out after checking
all the systems we didn't have any
technical issues y'all just broke the
damn internet regardless I know you guys
some of you guys did have trouble
getting on it was just because we had
half a city of people showing up at the
same time but anyways love you and I'm
going to be sending the free bonus for
people who showed up live to everyone
who registered you guys rock it's
amazing it was awesome day go grab some
books before they run out I think we
sold out of two-thirds of the books in
the first 20 minutes so hopefully
there's some right now you go to
shop.acquisition.com enjoy